on commence on y va on y va carrément
après avoir triomphé suscité un débat
sans précédent aux états unis sur le
thème est ce un film antisémite la
passion du christ de mel gibson arrive
en france sur 500 écrans avec jim cavier
zèle dans le rôle et la tunique
ensanglanté de jésus 2h06 de chair fous
étaient lacérés pour les 12 dernières
heures du christ pour son chemin de
croix un film évidemment en j'ai dit
bien évidemment en latin et en araméen
qui a déclenché outre-atlantique des
scènes d'hystérie mystique qui n'ont pas
encore atteint la france mais enfin on
est quand même à 80 mille entrées le
premier jour ce qui est assez phénoménal
j'ai oublié de dire que marie c'est maya
morgenstern n'est que marie-madeleine on
sent leur connaît bien c'est monica
bellucci je m'attendais à un judas
français dans le rôle
eh bien non c'est un italien c'est luca
lionello je salue d'emblée le meilleur
titre sur le film de la semaine écrit
par mon ami françois reynaert c'est ceci
est mon corps qui définit bien je trouve
ce film conte avez-vous pensé
mademoiselle k oui oh bah après
reinhardt comment voulez-vous faire moi
je pensais la fois où les x des fois
enfin pour le spectateur
non il faut il faut quand même juste
donné un mode d'emploi à ceux qui
n'auraient pas encore été voir le film
de mel gibson
il faut pas y aller après avoir bu un
café au lait ça tourne très vite il faut
éviter d'y aller moins de deux heures
après la fin de votre repas car vous ce
qui risque de rendre surtout si c'est un
tartare ceci dit vous risquez d'avoir
envie d'aller consommer à toute
berzingue un tartare à la sortie du film
enfin bon il ya comme ça une fenêtre
horaire assez particulière dans laquelle
on peut consommer un très gros sophisme
j'ai envie de dire c'est l'éternel débat
de la suggestion ou l'édification
lourdaude
je les ai vus en salles alors personne
ne veut me sais personne ne faisait
crise cardiaque tout le monde mangeait
son pop-corn d'un air assez hébété non
on se pose la question est-ce qu'il faut
suggérer comme le faisait pas au lit ni
avec un clou un coup de marteau sur un
clou et tout était dit de la barbarie
qui avait conduit jésus là où elle l'a
conduite ou est ce qu'on a besoin d'une
quincaillerie de psychopathe comme c'est
le cas dans le film de mel gibson pour
non plus suggérée mais affirmer souligné
jusqu'à la fin at nauseam quoi jusqu'à
l'écoeurement voilà moi j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir assisté au déploiement
des outils d'un psychopathe quincaillier
pendant deux heures qui livre une oeuvre
absolument oui effectivement ça a été
dit mais enfin re disons le enfonçant le
clou sadique publicitaire fait une sorte
de publicité hurlantes tridente criante
pour un catholicisme qui ne fait que
désigner des coupables qui oublie le
visage le visage de la miséricorde un
film pompiers quoi entre john woo et le
péplum des années 50 les lourds moche
éprouvant édifiant donc revoyons revoyez
la passion selon saint matthieu et
revoyez le set grâce ou thérèse sur la
foi voilà alors choisissons la fois et
pas les fois qu'on est chez elle à
ciment oui je me rappelle que dans
d'ange mécanique
alex dans ses rêves d'ultraviolence
s'imaginait pour se donner une
satisfaction sadique en centurion en
train de flageller le christ et on
voyait un plan du crime et je pense que
c'est à peu près ce niveau là
constituent cérons et de mel gibson est
une sorte d' alex un peu adolescents
attardés qui effectivement ne conçoit la
religion et look de l'histoire du christ
que comme une expérience hyperréaliste
de la souffrance une représentation
répéter on l'a dit épouvantable telles
que jeux on me l'avait décrit et c'est
vrai c'est exactement ce qui se passe
sur l'écran le christ déjà dès la
première année le premier plan il a déjà
l'oeil tuméfié on peut pas déjà le
l'imaginé plus abîmées et ça va être
comme ça pendant pendant deux heures
donc c'est un film assez terrifiant mais
je crois qu'il faut pas le prendre à la
légère je ne peux pas s'en amuser j'ai
vu des critiques anglo saxons très
cinéphile qui essayait de le récupérer
sous le côté en fait c'est un film à la
mario bava est un film d'épouvanté avec
tous les tout là et on peut le voir
comme ça avec le diable qui circule
d'ailleurs uniquement parmi les juifs le
diable est là donc il y à il ya toute
cette avec le ciel chargé d' orages avec
le tout un côté
effectivement cela surnaturel de films
d'horreur mais tout de même ça parle de
quelque chose de fondamental dans la
civilisation judéo-chrétienne et je
pense que ça a des implications pour les
gens qui vont voir
c'est vrai qu'on la dit que mel gibson
se rattache complètement à l'avant
vatican ii et même au moyen âge c'est
d'ailleurs le ce genre de de mystère de
la passion qu'ont joué dans les petites
villes allemandes et que les nerfs à
l'époque des nazis et qui avait un
succès considérable auprès du peuple du
peuple allemand qui dit il tient n'est
pas allé jusque là violence qu'il était
pas bien donc il n'a pas osé faire de
films de ce genre pour montrer que les
juifs étaient vraiment les les auteurs
delà de la mort du christ mais le côté
antisémite est absolument évident il est
il est permanent
on dit que le jésus dit à ponce pilate
que celui qui est coupable c'est celui
qui l'a donné c'est à dire qu'à yves qui
n'ont pas ponce pilate les romains sont
présentés comme des gens assumant
velléitaire alors qu on sait qu que
ponce pilate était un boucher et que
c'était les romains qui pratiquaient
pratiquer la crucifixion et la
flagellation par exemple dans l'évangile
c'est une ligne
c'est une deux lignes il en fait 20
minutes adnot et âme dans ce show que
c'est un film assez assez lamentable je
peux te fait d'accord pour dire que
c'est du point de vue cinématographique
c'est complètement nul il ya un travail
de qualité disons plastique non mais les
selles bon les flashbacks sont
grotesques jésus ans charpentier faisant
sa fin le public est en plein milieu
tout en soi reinhardt et pas toutes les
tentatives de sortir de la passion sont
nuls
mais c'est vrai que du point de vue par
exemple du point de vue de l'image de
travail lequel deschanel est beau il ya
le fini mais s'il ya le fini de films au
chili un but cela dit c'est un film
c'est un film qu'ils ont ça file
repoussant les cadets effet qu'edf est
incroyable que j'ai encore appris je
crois c'était hier qu aux etats-unis
qu'elle est un assassin est sorti de la
salle après la barbue et la police est à
la fois convertis en maintenant ses
livres et parce que les avait été
métamorphosée par la vue de ce film oui
je voulais simplement non mais moi je
voudrais simplement dire une chose c'est
que mel gibson non une seule dose mel
gibson a fait une chose remarquable
c'est qu'il a refusé que son fils soit
doublé et le film et en araméen et en
latin dans tous les pays du monde
ce qui était mieux que arte daniel et
c'est moche l'araméen oui c'est raté on
double ce qui est confortable quand même
c'est que on peut détester ce film
globalement voilà il n'ya rien à sauver
de ce film ni le fonds ni la forme ni
l'intention je suis sorti très énervé
depuis je me suis calmé
parce que franchement quand je suis
sorti de là j'avais exactement ce
sentiment qu'on a eu un moment avec le
pen quand le pen était très haut dans
les sondages et où on écrivait on disait
plus on en parle plus on en parle
faut pas en parler évidemment pour
gibson c'était trop tard
donc c'est quand même très
impressionnant de voir le triomphe de ce
film je ne peux pas le prendre à la
légère et qui va être planétaire qui va
être planétaire donc sur le plan
purement de l'antisémitisme évidemment
que c'est là parce que c'est là dans le
montage c'est à dire que la scène avec
ponce pilate qui est vraiment ponce
pilate c'est un brave mec un peu embêté
sa famille l'a peu embêté alors à mon
dieu quel point qu'elle tintouin alors
est il ya caïphe le grand prêtre de
jérusalem privé le crucifix tous les
rabbins et tous les rabbins tous les
très luxueux très chic ce retrait
rembrandt frère un chic sur et
effectivement quand il s'en lave les
mains c'est simplement parce qu'il a les
mains un peu poussiéreuse on lui amène
une bassine de dentiste et il se rase
les mains mais je veux dire c'est
effrayant c'est effrayant sur le fond je
pense que sur le plan de l'antisémitisme
ça n'arrivera les sentiments antisémites
que de second il les avait déjà mais
tout le reste est à l'avenant
tout le reste est à l'avenant et d'une
dune mythe d'une complaisance c'est
obscène c'est un film obscène
en effet bien costumes et bien maquillée
bien costumes et la seule je trouve qui
émerge de ce magma sanglant de ceux de
ce quartier de viande en plus même moi
qui ne suis pas chrétienne non mais une
seconde
moi qui ne suis pas chrétienne je pense
que ce film est plus choquant pour les
chrétiens que pour n'importe qui je
sauve marie maya morgenstern qui ne fait
rien et qui a un beau visage
enfin quelqu'un qui ne fait rien et qui
a un regard lui le pauvre christ il ne
l'a pas le regard puisqu'on lui fermer
l'oeil comme dans rocky iii cinq minutes
après le début
c'est un film ignoble avec oui je pense
que obscène c'est le bon mot sert que
c'est l'alliance de deux choses assez
détestable c'est le le spectacle
majoritaire et toutes les recettes tous
les trucs tous les effets du spectacle
majoritaire tellement majoritaire qu'il
en devient totalitaire et le
fondamentalisme religieux c'est
l'alliance entre les deux c'est à dire
que c'est un film est profondément
régressif et effectivement les gens qui
devrait choquer à saint nicolas du
jardin oui les gens qui doit être le
plus choqué par ce film c'est
effectivement les chrétiens parce que
mon dieu mais quelle régression quelle
régression après vatican ii
après des efforts les efforts bien
tardive ô combien trop tardif mais quand
même de l'église catholique sans pareil
des protestants externe mais pour
essayer d'arrêter quand même après des
siècles de persécution de montrer les
juifs comme le comme le peuple déicide
on en revient à ça mon dieu mais quelle
régression il faudrait comparer ça
effectivement avec l'évangile selon
saint matthieu de pasolini rossellini
pied voilà mais qu'ils étaient des films
daniel tu le sais bien aussi marqué par
leur temps parce que c'est un film des
années 60 la passion selon saint
matthieu et c'était effectivement une
passion ouverte tandis que là on est
dans une ambiance mondial de guerre de
religion d'antisémitisme larvée et le
film de ce point de vue là est un
symptôme c'est à dire qu'en 2003 2004
quand on fait une passion du christ il
faut que ça soit un fondamentaliste
chrétien qui la fasse et il faut
utiliser mes pires effets pour nous
montrer les juifs comme crucifères du
christ est insupportable c'est
insupportable et en plus moi je vais
jusqu'à penser et alors il faut peser
ses mots
bien sûr que tuer des gens et faire un
film ce n'est pas la même chose mais je
pense que tous les fondamentalismes
religieux profondément se ressemblent et
je pense que ces gens sont prêts à tout
pour vous marquez c'est à dire que quand
on sort de ce film on est littéralement
en état de terreur en état de choc
c'est en état de dégoût sont arrêtés à
lire qui a dû terrorisme
il ya des gens qui meurent dans des
tours il ya des gens qui meurent dans
des
train il ya aussi une forme de
terrorisme cinématographique je pèse mes
mots mais le but est le même nous
terroriser nous a vivir parce qu'on est
persuadé qu'en détient la vérité
c'est un film module la passion du
christ de mel gibson des réactions sur
ce film
non je vois que vous êtes tous tétanisés
je vous comprends
[Musique]